Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcasts for Monday for Monday.
Um,
July 8th how are you?
How is it going?
Wow,
this sounds really good to me.
I hope it sounded this good to you.
I think I nailed it.
What's up with these levels is fucking phenomenal.
Some too.
She's now going to Twitter me or tweet me whatever.
Ooh,
truly like the treble was a little too high.
Ah,
so was your mother when she was pregnant with
you fucking drunk.
Fetal cont years later.
Just walking around criticizing people and you know what?
It's not your fault.
It's because your mother,
first of all,
she was a horse.
Spread her legs,
no protection.
All the leaves,
leaves are brown and her legs.
I spread my legs as bay head.
Oh,
I could sing that whole song and annoy the shit out of you.
That's why I want to hear from next week people's whose mothers were whores and
they drank during pregnancy.
I want to hear what you think about world events.
That's what I want to hear.
Is that what you want to hear it?
Yeah,
it is.
It is what I want to hear.
It's my podcast.
Um,
I'm loving Twitter and I fucking hate it by the way.
I got to stop reading comments.
It's always people fucking correct.
And you,
you know,
I got this European tour coming up and someone was saying,
hey,
you're doing any of the smaller cities.
And I was like,
no,
just pretty much all I said,
all the capitals and it was like 10 countries and one fucking country.
It wasn't the capitol.
And I got like 20 people.
Oh,
[inaudible] Stuart lose not Blair's go.
He jokes
and it'll probably just be a nice,
they probably actually in reality in their heads when they were typing it,
they were actually going like,
I'm not trying to be Douche,
just letting you know.
It's not Glasgow and Edinburgh.
I'm just trying to help out.
This is just me over here in the back over here in my corner of the Internet,
just trying to help out.
That's probably how they were typing it.
But I'm such a negative Douche that I hear it in my head is,
oh,
that's how I hear it.
That's basically how I hear anybody telling me that I'm doing anything wrong or
you like me.
Isn't that exactly everybody,
all of a sudden,
no matter what language they're speaking,
like some fucking Asian person,
right.
Or some Asian motherfucker,
To keep it clean.
I'm call back to a special,
whenever the fuck I did that one,
um,
came up to me and we speaking out,
got her done Mike and see if he was up there speaking Asian,
if he was talking in his native language,
Korean,
whatever.
And it sounded like,
you know,
I thought,
I thought that was like right.
I would hear that like that if he was talking to somebody else.
But like if he felt I'd pulled into his parking spot,
it would just be like,
oh dog.
Which is just immediately sound like this guy.
He's a content,
you know,
even if I stole his spot and even if I knew he was right and I was wrong in the
moment,
I'm such a Dick that I,
I would,
I would block out that voice in my head going,
you know,
this guy's right,
this guy is right,
you know,
insulted them a little bit,
a little bit,
you know,
you kind of took his spot.
I would still block that out.
But the only thing that I can take positive out of it is as far as any sort of
like level of maturity that I have gained throughout my adult life is,
uh,
I,
at least now I recognize that I do that and I,
I'm actually,
I've gotten good enough that within 10 minutes of actually whoever I just called
the cunt and driving away,
I actually Kinda admit out loud in the car going in the car to myself going
like,
you know,
like I was right pill,
you kind of worry you were kind of the Douche.
So,
you know,
I try and get on your bad side,
but just next time let's try to,
you know,
try to hear the other person try to apologize.
Um,
so anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
I like seeing it that way.
This is the Monday morning podcasts.
Like when they say the Ohio State University,
which is one of the funniest bragging things ever.
You bragging about a state school when you fucked up in high school and you live
in Ohio and you can't go to any real university.
Then this is the college that you end up at.
Oh,
they love that one in Michigan.
But University of Michigan,
that's a state school too,
right?
Those are such weird schools.
Like University of Michigan,
right?
It's,
it's a state school.
So anybody did a keg stand instead of studying for math goes in and they live in
Michigan.
You end up there.
It's why their stadium.
That's where the fucking state,
he was so big,
you know,
bad banana.
Yay.
100,000 fucking people.
Do you think it's because the football programs,
is that good or it because that many people got a c in math in Michigan?
That's my question for you.
But if you,
if you live out of state,
it's like nine zillion dollars and you gotta be like a fucking,
you know,
half a physicist to get in there.
And you know,
it's funny,
I don't even know what a physicist does.
Do they study?
Physis
oh,
look at that over there.
Is that a physicist?
I Dunno.
How would you know I'm a physicist wants to do,
sorry.
The fuck is a fist as that physics,
are they the ones who study the inertia?
Um,
wow.
This is new level of ignorance.
Do you like that about this podcasts that rather than seeing me grow as a
person,
I'm,
I'm slowly regressing.
You know,
maybe you were already ahead of me.
Maybe you were a couple steps behind me.
Now they,
all of you,
it's like I'm that guy.
Like it's a foot race.
Right?
And I came out of the tracks,
uh,
out of the blocks,
sprinting,
you know,
now grabbing my sign.
You guys are just going around me,
you're still going to come.
And seventh,
you're not winning a medal,
but you beat me.
Right?
Makes you feel better,
doesn't it?
Well,
what does that say about you?
When we come back,
we'll be talking.
Um,
I went for a bike ride.
Go ahead and laugh.
It's a great thing to do.
I'm trying to keep the weight down,
you know,
because I read somewhere on the Internet,
and it was typical research on the Internet where you have a question and you're
just like,
ah,
you know,
why is the moon round?
Why is it round by the way?
Why if it wasn't just a block out there,
what would happen?
Ah,
Jesus,
he's 80 standup presence.
A presence premises is that I'm just throwing out here.
That would probably still work in the outer reaches of fucking Iowa.
Um,
any question you fucking have,
you go Google it on the Internet and then immediately you click on basically the
first fucking website you find you'll read it and you just take that as law.
At least I do.
That's what I do.
So one time,
I don't know how I came across this,
but they said basically every pound of fat on your body is another five miles of
capillaries that you have.
Your heart has to pump,
which is why even just be in five,
10 pounds over can significantly.
I did use that word and I did pronounce it correctly,
Sig,
that's five syllable word,
and everybody decrease your lifespan.
Okay.
You know,
I mean,
how would you like it if every day,
right?
You had to drive an extra five,
10 miles to work.
That's probably not a big deal,
but who's a pound overweight?
You know,
who's two pounds overweight after a certain age,
everybody's at least 10 15 pounds over.
Right.
What's 15 times five real quick?
That's 75 people.
What does he had to go an extra 75 miles to and from work everyday.
What kind of a fucking mood would you be?
Huh?
How much would your kids be running for their lives when you came walking up the
door,
up the path to the door.
That's what yeah,
is doing every time.
It beats when you're that fucking heavy.
Okay.
Just that heavy.
If forget about these ticket time bombs,
then I'll walk around 30 pounds overweight,
but there's still lifted weights.
Do it.
I'm alright.
You know,
touch my gut dude.
It's fucking Charlotte.
Yeah,
it's because you're fat.
You're fat is calcified.
It's so entrenched there.
It has squatter's rights right in front of your stomach.
You dumb fuck.
I love fat people who sit,
they skiff fucking fat and then they tell you how fucking the hard their stomach
is and they think it's like abs.
It isn't.
It's the fat is fucking jammed in there so tightly.
Like back in the day when they used to pack people into subway sneezed at
levels,
literally a job.
Your job was the fucking just leaning on the people and pack them in.
You know what I mean?
Oh my God.
That was the worst time in society for claustrophobic people slash the greatest
time ever for perverts.
You know,
it's just the entire spectrum.
Complete Fair to absolute ecstasy depending on who you are on that subway train.
But anyways,
that's what it is.
It's all you fatties out there who sit there and your fucking stomach is harder
than your head.
That's not abs.
That's not you.
Like,
oh well you know I'm so fat.
Every time I do is sit up in bed.
It's like I got a 45 pound,
you know weight number that you'd do that back in the eighties you put like it
wasn't enough to do set up.
She always had to add weight.
If you're doing dips,
they had that shit that literally looked like it was hanging like a fucking
metal tea bag hanging off of you.
You put the chain around your waist and then you'd hang weights off of that go.
He's fucking Dell and depths with like fucking two 25 hanging off his balls kid.
Right?
All that dumb shit.
That's what,
that's what fat people ethic.
They think I know a lot pap fat people right now.
Like why you always coming down or not?
So I'll tell you why.
Cause this kick a ginger day and I've never seen a fat person come to my rescue.
You don't give a fuck about me.
I don't give a fuck about you.
That's how it works.
Fatty.
All right with you.
Swollen face.
Um,
this is so unnecessarily mean right now.
I don't even know how I got onto this,
but I,
I have to see it through because I got an hour to do here.
People.
All right.
The fuck I was talking about pack.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I think these fat people with the hard stomachs,
they feel like when they just sit up in bed,
you know,
and they make that noise as they go to sit up and it just said,
right.
They think that's like,
that's why their stomach so hard rather than it's just jam packed with Syrup,
a new get in pancake batter
and all that other fucking gooey shit.
You know that they eat.
I'll tell you right now,
I think they should just get all those,
just get all the fatties and just get them out of the fucking country.
You know,
you bringing us down,
we've had it,
we had it with your kind.
They should stick all the fatties on a fucking island.
I want to run for political office at a very low level preaching like,
like what sounds like racism or nationalism,
but it,
it kind of affects,
everybody likes this fat people in every,
every race except the Asians.
It's very few Asians.
Every once in a while you see a fat Asian,
you just know he's hanging out with like Americans.
You know what I mean?
It's like there's no way you got fat eating a fucking great diet that you guys
have over there.
I don't know what it is over there,
but like,
people are in fucking shape and Asia,
you know,
I don't know about the Russians,
all that vodka that they're sucking down.
Okay.
Um,
how many more people can I offend in the first fucking 10 minutes as podcasts?
I'll 12 minutes in.
Okay.
That's okay.
So I've got a new 10 minutes to offend people.
Um,
yeah,
I think they should just run for office.
Okay.
And just,
just be like,
I get the fatties out of town.
I get those fucking people,
uh,
yields people.
You say hello and they don't say hello back.
They just smile and it's a fake smile.
I know I've talked about this in my podcast.
There was somebody when I lived in New York,
used to do that and I fell for it like the first 67 times I'd be walking down
the hall and this
would be walking the other way with her fucking kids and always just be,
I'd be like,
Hey,
good morning.
Or Hey,
after I,
you know,
hello or good afternoon,
whatever the fuck you say.
Right.
Big fucking wave.
A fellow human being being polite,
how are ya?
Alright.
And she would always do the same thing.
She tilts her head to the side,
like she was gone.
Aw.
And then she do this smile,
which she,
she wouldn't show any teeth,
just like the Jay Leno smile.
And then her eyes would,
would like squint up.
Like she was looking into the sun,
big stupid red lipstick.
And every fucking time I was just like,
oh,
what if I just fucking punched her right in the face,
made her kids cry.
And I just laughed.
I didn't laugh.
I just walked away.
You know?
I'd still be effected.
That'd be a part of my soul that I lost when I did it.
But I'll tell you in that moment,
and nap catcher,
right as she closes her eyes,
you know,
like a fucking off Samuelson move.
Don't even drop the glove keeping on and it just blast or right in the face.
And I wanted to do that every fucking time.
Yeah.
And then finally one day she walked towards me and I was walking towards her and
uh,
she actually started to anticipate me saying hello,
because we're looking right at each other and I'm in my head just going,
I'm not saying anything,
I'm not saying hello to this bitch says hello to me.
This is another thing that makes you die early.
You know,
he's fucking literally sitting in your apartment,
you little ass shoe box of apartment in New York,
plotting,
scheming,
conspiring.
Uh,
how are you going to fucking not say a load of this bitch sit next time you see
her,
you know,
as you're eating a bacon,
egg and cheese and added an extra couple of miles for you had to beat every
couple of times,
right?
So anyway,
she comes walking at me,
I'm walking around,
I'm like,
I'm not fucking saying hello this time,
you know?
And we got right to the where it's like,
who's going to blink?
And I timed it perfectly.
She anticipated me saying hello when she started to tilt her head and I fucking
did my impression of what she did.
And I of course did it completely over the top.
Like I literally laid my head on my shoulders,
squinted my eyes,
and I made this ridiculous face and continued to walk and she never looked at me
in the hall again.
And this is the genius of it.
She just,
it's not like she knows what the fuck she looks like.
I'm so self involved.
I assume she totally understood my point,
what I was trying to make,
you know,
like say hello,
stop making that stupid face.
She probably looked at like,
what the fuck is what that guy,
he has some sort of mental tick.
I don't want him around my children,
but you know what?
It made me feel better.
And you know what?
That is what this podcast is all about.
Um,
hey people,
have you ever heard a Tivo?
But where the hell your bed?
Yeah.
Well you got,
you got your head up,
your Aa Devos,
the greatest.
Especially,
you know,
we really appreciate it.
An old fella like myself,
you know why?
Cause back in the day back in,
I gotta explain this to you guys.
Back in the day when you miss something,
you just missed it.
It was over,
or at least on the,
if you didn't see it in the movie theater,
that's it.
You missed it.
There was no Netflix,
there was no,
uh,
the shop than.com that you watch it on.
I don't know.
It was over.
You missed it.
Evil Knievel was going to jump over 20 buses,
but for some reason your parents wanted you to take it a pewter pot to go get a
muffin and you missed it.
And the next day you were down at the bus stop at,
everyone was talking about it and you were a man without a country.
Okay.
And you knew eventually it was going to come around to you and they were like,
did you see it?
And you were like,
no.
Well you didn't see it.
No,
I didn't see it.
I was getting muffins with my parents and then just a rain of book bags would
just be smashing you over the head and that's what happened.
But thankfully that never happens to children anymore because the Tiva back in
the day,
TV was weirdly had to watch.
You only watch a show at a certain time and if you missed it or even part of it,
you literally had to wait for it to go into reruns before you could see it
again.
Tivo has totally changed all of that and while other DV eyes exist,
they're not as awesome as Tivo.
You know why?
Because if you have cable,
cable TV lets you watch your shows wherever you want.
With Tivo Stream,
you can watch on your iPad all over your house and even transfer your favorite
recordings and take them with you on an airplane waiting in line at the DMV
dentist's office.
You can be sitting there watching all of the Sopranos.
Tivo makes a other dvrs look like they were designed by the Soviet community.
I like this copy.
Only Tivo reaches both cable and web to find any movie,
any show,
any video at the press of a button.
All right,
so there you go.
From the couch to the kitchen from the minivan to 35,000 feet,
Tivo makes TV 100,000 times better.
So why don't you do yourself a huge favor and go get some,
go get yourself some Tivo.
Have you heard about that?
Tivo?
Oh my God,
I want to get some.
Um,
all right,
let's do one other here.
Then we'll get back to a dollar shave club.
Everybody.
How many times have you walked into cvs and said,
hey,
I need a the triple blade plus,
uh,
can I get one of those?
And they go,
yet,
that'll be $68.
And you're like $68.
So like,
yeah,
that's why we keep it locked behind the case here,
like at some vintage guitar rather than some piece of plastic with a poor excuse
for metal to drag across your face.
That's going to be useless in five days.
You know,
probably ended up floating around in the ocean,
poking up some porpoises I,
why is that?
Thanks so much money.
You know why?
Cause it's a scam.
We'll finally,
the cavalry is here when it comes to shaving,
um,
dollar shave club.
Everybody getting in good shape can be a real pain in the age,
searching through 50 brands,
making new blades,
matching new blades to old handles,
bullshit features where your razors doubles as a flashlight,
a toothpick and et cetera.
20 bucks for new razors to hell with that,
go to dollar shave club.com to get high quality razors delivered to your door
for just a couple of bucks a month.
And that Greg no longer standing in line at those long lines at cvs when you're
behind anyone from a doctor to some crack addict waiting to get,
try to find the one person working on the Florida unlocked the raises.
Now they deliver them right to you for a fraction of the cost.
They've made it simple,
high quality raises a hundred percent guaranteed sent on scheduled so you never
have to think about it again.
Every month.
You get a new pack every week you change your blade and it costs a fraction of
what you pay at retail.
Um,
you've want to support this show.
Got a dollar shave club.com,
forward slash burr,
or click on the dollar shave club banner on the podcastPage@billbird.com.
There you go.
Look at me.
Look at me,
saving you money,
saving you money.
So it's been a hell of a week everybody.
It's always been hell of a week.
You know,
if you try to stay up on world events,
there's always something crazy going on right over in Egypt.
You know where the Arab spring began as far as I can remember,
you know,
they elected a president and within a year they're like,
you know what,
we don't like this guy.
Why don't we have a new election?
And then the new guys like,
Nah,
I'm in here.
I'm not leaving.
And they go,
Oh yeah,
we think you are.
And he goes,
oh,
I don't think I am there.
I bet you are.
I'm now,
I bet.
I doubt.
I Bet I don't.
Next.
He know this riots in the streets,
you know,
when isn't it a hell of a week?
Okay.
Sorry.
Can you tell him searching for something as a way the fuck is it?
I swear to God,
I swear to God.
This is the exact kind of thing that just slowly fucking drives me mad about
these Goddamn fucking computers.
What did I do wrong this time?
Ghost of Steve Jobs and watch this.
I'm going to try to do this.
Move that it finally work.
Did it finally work?
Oh,
here it is.
I got it.
Sorry.
MMM.
Put it on.
Want to talk about,
oh,
I know Aaron Hernandez.
Everybody.
Yeah.
You know what?
One of the whole fucking hilarious things about Aaron Hernandez case is I'm
fucking sitting here calling up my buddies and people are so into sports in
Boston.
Okay.
Like the fact that somebody lost their life.
That's like,
that's like on page 19 of this story.
I called my buddies back there and they're all like,
dough now.
Now what are we going to do?
You know,
Bronx always getting hurt.
They traded fucking Welker.
Right?
Who's Brady going to throw to?
They don't.
They like,
they're not even thinking like,
you know,
sports kind of takes a back seat to this unbelievably like bizarre,
depressing,
sad,
horrific fucking story.
You know,
who gives a fuck if we can beat the dolphins are not,
you know,
I dunno.
There's a big,
there's a big pity party going on in Boston.
Look,
oh my God,
this is like the worst week ever.
Well,
we had the greatest decade ever.
All right.
And I stand by that.
Anybody in any state in the United States,
if you want to challenge the last 10 years of Boston sports,
bring it on.
Bring it on.
I want to know one of the fucking city that one off for the major titles.
Numerous times.
Three Superbowls,
two world series,
a Stanley Cup in an NBA championship within 10 fucking years.
Went to five Superbowls to Stanley Cup finals to NBA finals.
Fucking unbelievable.
All right.
And all you guys now who are gleeful and other in all your other sports towns
and you think you're going to fucking bug me with your little Cunty tweets?
No,
that,
I know this.
You would cut off your one of your fucking sports watch sport watching balls to
experience half the fucking success that Boston had over the last 10 years.
You would take this week of horror.
You would definitely trade it.
All right.
You would do it.
You trade in your fucking Mark Sanchez Jersey.
Do I swear to God jets fans would,
would,
would take this week just to fucking make it back to the super bowl.
Do you know the last time the jets were in the Superbowl,
we hadn't even pretended to be on the moon yet?
Do you realize how long ago that was?
You know
Richard Nixon was still,
it was a comeback story.
He was like Travolta pulp fiction.
That's how fucking long ago it was there.
That's another thing they got do.
What if he gets acquitted?
Right.
And then he fucking signs with the jets.
You know,
that was actually my thought because I don't think as far as from what I've
seen,
unless his friends flip on them or unless they have some unbelievable piece of
evidence that they have not introduced to the public yet.
What you basically have is a mountain of circumstantial evidence against a
mountain of money.
And as far as my little experience of watching the court case,
the rich guy walk,
he was just an Aaron Hernandez waiting for a bus.
You know,
pimp my ride.
I'm driving a piece of shit,
a exhibit.
Can you put a fucking fish tank in the back of this thing?
Right.
If he was something like that over working in a warehouse,
unloading trucks like,
oh Billy red face back in the day,
Don,
you're going to jail.
All right,
but you got,
you got,
you know,
okay.
Fucking pro athlete money.
You can walk.
You know,
some lay on ESPN wrote,
the dumbest article was saying that despite the fact of how quickly the Patriots
acted,
once they found out all these allegations against Aaron Hernandez and released
him like this,
black mark will always forever,
forever everybody forever.
We'll stay in the patriots.
Like if for some reason we don't steer the and into the sun and the next 300
years,
there's going to be people 300 years from now still talking about Aaron
Hernandez still thinking about it every time they see the Patriot logo is,
that isn't the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life.
You know
when you watch a Carolina Panthers game,
when was the last time you thought about Ray Carus
get out?
Nobody remembers.
Nobody fucking remembers.
This will be something dude.
You know that was a guy in the Kansas city chiefs that killed his whole family
and then himself after football.
I don't know what,
maybe he got hit in the head too many.
I don't know what happened,
Dude.
I never heard of the story until Len Dawson brought it up.
It goes away.
Do you know a guide on the jets used to take his dick out in port,
the port authority.
He died his pubes grain and he'd fall,
can shake his dick at people,
you know,
and it was so shocked looking at his green pubes.
I never took the longest time before somebody finally looked at his face and
then they,
uh,
then they arrested him and no one ever thinks about that when they watch a jets
game.
Do they see that's my point.
You guys can look all this up.
This all,
I don't know if you find the last one,
but the other ones you'll find,
oh,
Jesus.
Joe,
what do you think if they turned,
put dry a into a flanker they could join the combination of him and that Jesus
Freak.
They could somehow make up for Hernandez going to jail.
Um,
all right.
I don't even know what I'm talking about right now to be honest with Ya.
Hey,
this weekend,
speaking of Boston,
I'm going to be a,
I'm going to be doing with the Cape Cod Melody Tent.
Why?
How come,
why did I,
did I just add a syllable to Melton mellow melody,
the Cape Cod Melody tent in Hyannis.
Is it in Hyannis somewhere down near the Kennedy compound.
They sit,
they're spending all their fucking booze money down there.
It was not what they did.
The prohibition money,
the red side of trading money.
Um,
I have no idea what the fuck they did.
All I know is they don't,
they have a big yellow house and they go out and they played touch football.
That turns into tackle football.
And then it just big family fight because they're like a bunch of pit bulls or
if they fuck that gene out of there,
their family at this point,
it's just all watered down.
You know,
too many weak men and women brought into the fold.
you ever think about that shit?
Like when Pete,
you know,
what's the worst thing ever is when somebody gives the son or daughter of a
father,
a mother that accomplished something great.
They always give the kids shit.
Like it's the kid's fault.
Like if you're the son of fucking Michael Jordan or the daughter of Amelia
Earhart,
um,
people will always be like,
dude,
you're not,
you're not as good as your father,
blah,
blah.
And they blame you.
It's like,
it's not my fault that I'm half cut with my mom.
You know,
my dad can jump out of the gym.
My mother trips over a mop handle every fucking three days.
So I got 50% of that and me weighing me down.
I can still dunk.
But no,
I can't take off from the foul line.
That's not my fault.
It has nothing to do with my desire or my heart or anything like that.
It has to do with my mother.
And the same thing with like Amelia Earhart's kid.
If she had a kid,
I don't know,
she probably didn't have a kid.
No guy can handle that.
Back in the day when she was supposed to be in the fucking kitchen making sugar
cookies,
she's out there flying around doing better than the guys
match.
Why I had a dick shape.
I'm not fucking that her hair so short,
right?
No guy can handle that.
I have no idea.
Did she have a kid?
Did she take them on the trip?
Maybe that's why she crashed.
You know,
if the kid was acting up,
she was reaching back trying to slap him in the face,
like how you could as a parent back then.
And,
uh,
she went into the ocean.
Who knows?
Who knows why these things happen?
Everybody,
I don't,
I don't pretend to know.
And you know what?
More importantly,
I don't want to know.
But anyways,
back to the,
to the Boston sports things.
Boston fans,
you know,
not,
you're not all crying,
but the ones who are bitching,
I don't want to fucking hear it.
All right.
Quit your fucking crying and everyone else in your other towns try enjoy this
week as much as you can because we'd been kicking all your fucking ass for 10
years.
And you know,
it's true,
at least mostly true.
You know,
the only people give a shit as giants fans.
And that's just when it comes to football,
right?
But some of them are Yankee fans.
And I'll take those two Superbowl losses for what we did to the Yankees in 2004.
I'll take that all day long.
Now there's one that will live forever,
that unlike the Hernandez thing,
that will live forever because you know what's great about it,
there's no way to beat it.
There's no way to beat it.
And even though TV,
even the Bruins lost four in a row and hockey.
Right,
but we didn't have the level of fucking hall of fame.
It's fucking great.
It'd be like if Babe Ruth Lou Gehrig and you had Dimaggio and Mickey Mantle all
on the same thing,
I know what you guys are saying.
That's not true.
When I say fuck you,
fuck you and your pin stripe heart.
It's true the way you guys,
we'll load it up a free agent.
She couldn't do that back in the day.
Back in the day he had to fucking earn it as opposed to now we can go out and
buy it.
Los Angeles Lakers,
you know?
Anyways,
I love how Dwight Howard,
Dwight Howard leaves the Lakers and they're sitting there questioning his heart
and all that and never once again,
never did they think,
well,
why would you want to leave?
Why would you want to leave?
Gee,
what could it be?
The fucking 800 pound gorilla?
How many great centers have to leave town saying,
I really didn't have a good fucking time playing with all,
what's his face over there?
How many hall of fame coaches have to write books where if you read through the
subtext that kind of go,
hey,
that guy's kind of a cunt.
It's kind of a cut to be around.
You know who says that about somebody they won a championship with?
You know,
this is my impression of a Los Angeles Laker Fan.
As a parent,
uh,
the kid comes home if their kid was Aaron Hernandez and came home and actually
admitted to murdering two people,
and then the third one,
you know what the mother and father would do,
they would stand up on the coffee table and they would start chanting MVP.
All right?
That might be,
admittedly,
that's a little harsh,
but I'm just saying I am a less than impressed with the average knowledge of
sports that a Laker fan has.
It's just fucking dumb.
I'm just dumbfounded,
dumbfounded that not in not even once did you ever boot Koby Bryant when he
walked off the court on your whole fucking team.
I just said,
fuck ag.
Trying to think
of a major city that would put up with that.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
maybe it's the sun.
Maybe it's the pot cookies.
I don't know what.
Anyways.
All right.
Here we go.
We got,
we got some fucking,
uh,
we got some letters.
All right.
Billy Bean bag is a new one.
Billy Bean from the Oakland A's Billy Bean bag.
I get it.
Beanbag.
A a revolutionary chair dude.
How bad was it?
Bean bag for the environment when she threw that thing out.
It was made out of this,
this blend.
You're like when they blend like a scotch,
not scotch.
Yeah.
Scotch is this guy.
I don't fucking know.
A whiskey.
It's a blend.
A wine where you pour like a cabernet inter Merlow some real white trash shit.
This is like that,
that this is the chair version of that.
It was like a pillow.
It was a chair.
It was a fat person's stomach.
It was everything,
right?
It was food that astronauts eight out in space.
I think it was like filled with like,
I dunno,
like these little,
whatever the fuck you call those things.
What are those things in the coffee cups used to be made out of and you'd sit
there and scratch them and let it go into the environment back in the 70s before
you realize that birds were inhaling it and it was like Agent Orange or minor
long or something black lung.
Is that what it was?
Gee,
I don't know bill,
you're the one who started riffing on beanbags and realize that you didn't even
know what material it was made of.
Styrofoam.
They were filled with styrofoam and then like the outside of it was like a blend
of like plastic,
vinyl and uh,
you know,
some sort of treated waste.
Yeah.
And then you had the upscale ones where they are actually made out of the lab.
Uh,
my dad,
we got a bunch of bean bags and they were all plastic,
vinyl hunks of shit,
but his was a leather one and we just think it was the shit big fucking,
and you'd grab it,
right?
This is how you set up a B bag.
You grab it by the top,
like how your mother used to pick you up by your hair before she hit you with a
wooden spoon.
You know,
cause you're watching cartoons.
Um,
instead of doing your homework back when you could hit children in public or the
safety of your own home,
when he had company,
you'd pick it up and give it a shake,
right?
And then you would just push it right down the middle and then you'd sit on the
fucking thing and it was horrifically uncomfortable and it's a good five years
before people realized it.
You know,
when people just bought them because everybody else had them.
Oh it's so easy.
You can move them around the rom look how easy it is.
The vacuum under and I can pick it up and vacuum.
I see.
Can't do that with a chair.
Um,
I wonder where all of those ended up.
You know,
you know who gives a fuck,
right?
Sitting here reminiscing about chairs from the early seventies.
All right,
Billy Bean bag.
Have you heard of Justin Carter?
This 19 year old kid has been in jail since March for making a sarcastic remark.
Here's an excerpt from a report,
uh,
after a Facebook friend with whom he played video games,
described him as crazy and messed up in the head.
Carter replied sarcastically.
One imagines,
uh Oh yeah,
I'm really messed up in the head.
I'm going to shoot up a school full of kids and eat.
They're still beating hearts.
He added lol and j k.
Just kidding.
For good measure for this.
He was arrested by Austin police,
charged with making a terrorist threat and thrown into prison.
He may language there until the start of the next decade.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Crazy stuff,
Bill.
This isn't Russia.
Is this Russia?
Okay,
I know.
So you do this is that Snowden shit.
This is like all of that,
but just slowly becoming this fucking police state.
You know what it is to people.
You've got to stop fucking putting shit down and print.
That's just keep it how we,
we used to say shit like that,
but we set it on the playground.
Okay.
You know?
Oh yeah.
Like,
I'm going to go shoot the principal and the head.
That's what you do,
you know,
fucking write it down on the guide.
You know,
by though it was there any sort of backlash against Facebook for basically
ratting out all US citizens,
you know,
turning us all into the man,
man.
You know,
he is still using Facebook.
I barely used it anyways.
You know,
I still go there and I checked fucking emails,
but in the back of my head I'm like,
why am I using this guy's Cunty fucking a,
what do you call it,
social media thing here.
You know,
when he turned the fucking record,
how much money did he make to turn out and ran everybody out?
Okay.
Know,
I swear to God,
if you're one of those fucking people who's dumb enough to be like,
well,
it's yeah,
the terrorist
you got nothing to worry about.
Yeah.
I have no sympathy for you.
When I see you in the Fema camp with me,
you know,
and that's what I'm going to do.
That's the only way that's going to keep the joy in my heart is when I'm on the
upper bunk in your,
in the lower bunk across the way.
I'm just going to,
for the rest of my minutes on earth,
I'm just going to keep looking at you going,
yeah.
Are you going to worry about
over and fucking over until basically beaten to death by the other people in
there?
Don't want to hear it anymore
on that.
Creeped me out.
Um,
okay.
I don't,
I don't know why this kid isn't it.
He's still in jail.
Okay.
Uh,
I,
I don't know what to think about it.
I have to know,
you know.
Okay.
Does he have a weird haircut and a trench coat that freaked them out?
I mean,
it is Texas.
Texas has always kind of been their own deal.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
they kill people in Texas the way they rescued dogs here in la.
So I don't know.
I feel about that.
I mean,
as far as like population,
it's phenomenal.
But as far as their swift,
uh,
I dunno,
I just can't imagine getting put to death for something he didn't do.
And you walk in down there,
uh,
like how does that work in the afterlife when you go to get judged?
Are you allowed to yell at God at that point?
Like when he starts,
you know,
reviewing your life,
you just stand there like,
dude,
don't even fucking start with me.
Alright.
Right.
Just open the goddamn gates already.
Okay.
You know how this story against,
you know everything,
right?
Oh,
I know everything.
Yeah.
You knew everything except how to get me out of that.
How come you,
how come you didn't help me or how come you,
you fucking helped every,
uh,
a bunch of people and then you just stopped talking to people,
you know,
hey,
let me finish.
Where was my burning Bush?
Where was that?
Well,
I'll write down,
um,
hey,
here's some inspirational shit here.
Somebody wrote.
So Miss [inaudible] some inspiration for the Monday morning podcast.
It says bill,
it's like that thing I read on the internet once said,
plant three rows of peace,
peace of mind,
peace of heart,
peace of soul.
I really hope nobody's eating is,
I read the rest of this plant,
three rows of squash,
squash and difference.
Squash,
selfishness,
squash,
hate.
Oh,
Jesus is another one.
Plant three rows of lettuce.
Let us be kind.
Let us love one another.
Let us grow our own food.
Oh,
why?
All of that is great.
And if everybody applied that the world would be such a wonderful place.
Why does that make you fucking,
you grind your teeth to listen to though what it can,
you know?
That's a great question.
You know,
at least I consider it a great question.
I'm in my own head here,
man.
It sounded awesome to me.
Seemed like a good thought.
And then I said it and I was like,
wow,
how did I come up with that one?
You guys might disagree,
but what?
Why is that?
Who doesn't want peace of mind?
Peace of heart.
But you know why?
Because it's a fucking pun.
Ps of mine,
you know,
squash,
indifference.
A lot of people don't know what indifference means.
Okay.
And I,
I think I'm one of them in difference means you have,
like when somebody goes,
do you want this?
You want that?
Hey,
I'm in different,
okay.
I think it doesn't exist for me.
And you,
you don't,
you don't love it or hate it.
You have absolutely no opinion on it whatsoever.
Um,
it,
which like,
I don't know how to be like that.
I don't think anybody's in different,
that's like God,
like,
that's like a higher level of fucking thought in my world,
you know?
Hey,
what do you think about these drapes?
I immediately like,
you know,
they're all right.
I like them.
They're hideous.
I know.
Just look at something like,
what do you think about this?
I have no thought whatsoever.
I don't know what that is.
What are you think about this band?
Yeah,
they're all right.
That's the closest I get to indifferent.
You know,
it built,
why don't you look up the fucking word first before you make,
ah,
just takes time.
Fucking reading,
you know,
get a life.
Um,
speaking of rescuing dogs,
I was out with the lovely near the,
uh,
yesterday
and we were driving around looking at houses.
It's like something we like doing.
Um,
but it sucks because then you're,
you're always there are always better than your house,
cause you never go out and look at houses that are the same as yours.
You're like,
hey,
let's go out,
look at Shit we can't afford.
Right.
You go in the house like,
oh my God,
this is awesome.
It just,
with every house,
you just kind of gone.
I live in a fucking tree fort,
but it's still fun to do,
you know?
And I feel like I'm actually helping the owner of the house because,
uh,
by going in there and I'm walking around,
you know,
anybody else who's in there,
they're thinking like,
Oh shit,
this guy might make an offer.
I got,
I got to jump on this.
You know,
that's how I justify me just going in there and looking at people's closets.
Um,
so anyways,
that's what we were doing yesterday.
And,
uh,
so what did we do?
We went.
So we went to the grocery store.
Oh yeah.
To get some shit for dinner and next door there was this place where they had,
uh,
you don't rescue some dogs.
So she's just like,
oh,
let's go over and look at the dog.
It's like,
I don't want to go over there.
I don't want go over there and look up late.
Some chewed up fucking animal that's gonna make me feel fucking horrible and
I'll be laying in bed thinking about the dog,
like in no country for old man,
when the dude sitting there laying there and he thinks about that guy that was
asking for water,
Eh,
whatever he says that Gaf fuck it.
Right.
You got to go back there and next thing you know you got some psycho chasing.
Yes.
[inaudible] that's not gonna happen.
But I'm just saying I'm going to be thinking I love dogs too much that I can't
go down and look at him cause now I'm going to be just fucking thinking about
them.
So she's like,
I could fine.
Fine.
Just stop doing that.
Right.
So we go over there,
okay.
And we walk in and there's this fucking pit bull that's like two weight classes
up from our dog.
Big Classic fucking beautiful pity head.
And I can't even tell you what color this thing was.
It was like,
um,
it wasn't Carmel,
it was like this almost sandy kind of color.
Okay.
With no white or anything,
just not patches,
just that color.
The fucking dog was beautiful and it had to weigh every bit of 80 pounds,
all muscle.
And it was an absolute sweetheart.
Like he came in and the thing is just fucking doing that thing where it's
wagging its tail so hard.
It looks like it's shaking it's ass and it's walking sideways is you come up to
it and it just buries that big head like right in your lap.
And then at one point I'm petting a thing and it just fucking just leans into me
like I was squat down like a ketchup patch,
petting it and it wants to be pet more.
So it just sort of relaxed his body and leaned into me and literally like
knocked me over and I fell down.
And then it went over and started like licking my face was a greatest fuck this,
this all basically happen in about 11 seconds.
And then all of a sudden this lady comes walking over
and the most annoying I'm talking to a dog voice ever just comes walking in.
Yeah.
That's fucking doing that.
And it was like my eyes started watering and I just fucking stood up and walked
away.
Nia said something like,
okay.
And then that happened.
She said something loud enough that the girl heard but she couldn't hear
anything
and whatever the dog's name was like Franklin choosing.
Yeah,
no.
And that shit.
And just,
he just stood up and just fucking walked away.
So now I'm over the other side of the pet store buying shit bags is a Michael
Rappaport called the back of the day shitbags bags.
Um,
yeah,
I fucking,
I'm buying those and within two seconds,
this woman left with that dog.
Yeah.
Like walked in,
saw it and just left with this 80 pound fucking dog.
Yeah.
And uh,
okay.
I had this such mixed emotions.
I was excited that the dog got rescued.
Yeah.
And I was bombed that that was the person that rescued it.
Okay.
You know?
I don't know why she loved dogs the same way I did.
She did a great thing.
Like why should I be bumped?
She just fucking,
and you know what it was.
It was I wanting to keep playing with the dog.
You came in with your fucking Jerry Lewis Voice from hell.
They just say from Hell yes I did.
It's the eighties comedy week.
Um,
all right.
What are we,
are we 47 minutes in cheese,
Luis?
All right,
let's continue on here.
Oh,
I started to mention that I went on this bike ride by the way.
And a,
for those of you who live out here in la or are you coming to visit,
um,
you can actually ride a bicycle all the way up to the Hollywood sign.
And,
uh,
it is one of the hardest bike rides I've ever fucking been on.
You keep seeing the sign and every time you go around a corner and you just
think this has to be the last fucking corn up before I'm up here,
you know?
And it just isn't and then it isn't and it isn't any,
just keep fucking going and going and going.
It was like the ascent to use a word that's beyond my key vocabulary.
You already had to go all the way up the canyon,
just get to the,
to the beginning of like,
okay,
now we're going to get to the summit here,
right to use mountain climbing,
Shit.
Just that a sin you already fucking road like a half hour just to get up there.
And then this is sent is I swear to God,
maybe 20,
25 straight minutes of,
I don't know what it is,
45 degree angle.
It's fucking brutal.
And then at some points,
especially right at the end when it gets even like 60 degrees,
it's fucking ridiculous.
And uh,
I was beyond gasping for wheezing.
Okay.
I wrote and I stopped.
Right.
You know where they have the radio antennas?
You're actually above the sign,
got off the bike and grabbed the chain link fence and was gone.
Okay.
For fucking like five fucking,
I thought I was going to pass out.
Um,
but you know what?
I probably knocked off some miles on the capillaries there.
Um,
so anyways,
but you know what's great as you going up,
there's all these guys dress like Lance Armstrong calming down and they all give
you words of encouragement because they just did it,
you know,
and I'm going up there on a mountain bike made for a lady.
So when I got for Nia that she never fucking road.
And uh,
I love riding women's bicycles,
you know,
like women's bicycles that designed the way guys bicycle should be
okay.
I always thought they had that reverse.
Well basically they shouldn't bang their clit on something metal,
although no one,
those psychos,
they probably fucking a joy.
It,
you know,
um,
harder.
Uh,
the way the woman's bicycle is fucking like this,
so concerned about their dresses and you look it up and seeing that clam that
once again seeing their clam is,
is,
you know,
hiding their clam is more important than somebody else's smashed testes.
Okay.
Um,
I go up to,
it's not like the old school Schwinn one way and when all the way down to like
your ankles,
but it's angled to the point where I can get my feet down and a old Ricky,
Ricky,
Bobby,
you're going to be okay.
You know,
so I don't have a problem with it.
I have sort of a,
uh,
an androgynous bike that I ride yet.
Oh,
it's a mountain bike,
but it's not a guy's bike and it's not a bike is kind of,
it's,
you know,
it sounds a little questionable.
Don't I have,
I have the don't ask,
don't tell Huffy then I ride.
Um,
and I'm not going to apologize for it,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
All right.
Got My ass kicked bill.
I'll keep this short and sweet because I know how bad you are at reading things.
You know,
I can't even argue that,
uh,
he goes,
I live in a small city,
roughly 90,000 people.
What do you live in China?
Is that a little village?
Do 90,000 fucking people.
That's gigantic.
The nightlife district of the city has more or less 10 different bars or clubs.
I,
by the way,
before people are Dicks to me on the Internet.
I mean that's,
that's gigantic.
If you say that you,
you live in a small town,
well I guess it's small.
He said city.
Ah,
right.
You're right.
I'm an asshole.
Okay,
here we go.
The nightlife district of the city has more or less 10 different bars or clubs.
Well,
how big are they?
If there's 90,000 people in there,
you've got to think at least half of them drink
10 bars or clubs get 4,500 people in each one.
It doesn't make any sense.
Uh,
last weekend I left all my friends at one bar to go meet up with a girl at
another while there I was heavily intoxicated and grabbed the lady's ass I was
meeting.
Apparently two drunk guys didn't take too kindly to this and decided to attack
me and gave me a good baiting somehow.
I think you left some,
some details.
Did you grab the ass or the woman you were talking?
So,
um,
we're that her two older brothers and you were to hammer to realize it anyways.
He goes,
it's hard to show my face back in this club again after I got beat up.
Should I just man up and going again next weekend?
Like I own the joint and if I see the two guys,
should I get my group to give them a good ass kicking along with me?
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Um,
okay.
All right.
First of all,
you got,
he didn't psyche lost to one guy.
He lost the two people,
you know?
Okay.
So I don't think that's a,
uh,
I think the embarrassing thing is that you grabbed the woman's ass.
I need to know more details about that.
So let's just say that these two guys would jealous because they wanted to fuck
her and you came in.
Um,
Sean was going on.
Somehow they were connected to that woman.
All right,
well,
here's the first lesson.
All right.
If you go on into a bar to meet some lady,
some strange lady that you don't have a relationship with,
you know,
that's,
do use my analogy last week.
That's an away game.
Okay.
Would you go into the bleachers wearing the other team's fucking Jersey by
yourself?
You need,
you need,
next time you go in there,
you need to bring some friends.
Um,
I think you just go in there and you're asking for trouble.
Uh,
one way or the other that you go back in there with some friends,
you're going to end up in,
uh,
either jail or the hospital,
one or the other.
That's it.
Either way you're going to end up in court either sewing because you don't have
a fucking,
you know,
you got a droopy eye now or just,
it's just you don't want to do that.
You don't,
all right.
You went in there,
you were drunk.
You know what,
dude,
this is really on you.
This is on you.
Uh,
you will careless with yourself.
I'm going to blame you the way they used to blame rape victims back in the day.
All right?
You weren't dressed like a whore,
but you will.
You were doing the dressing like a whore version for a being a guy.
You walked in,
they're all sloppy.
You rocked into somebody else's bar,
you grabbed one of their women,
you started squeezing her ass,
like you would test it out some Shaban.
Right?
And then you got beat down.
This should be a life lesson for you.
All right?
If you're going to do some Donnie Brasco bar shit,
you gotta,
you gotta have,
you gotta have a crew with you and you have to be sober and uh,
don't grab her ass until you talk her into fucking to you back in her apartment.
That's when you do the ass grabbing.
Do not go into,
do not go into a bar.
Especially,
you know,
within a day it's a division rivalry.
You know what I mean?
Like as a patriots fan,
you would never go down to the metal lands and start grabbing some jets,
chicks ass.
That's it.
You're going to get a Hibachi over your fucking head and vice versa.
Vice versa there.
So there you go.
There's your advice,
revenge,
uh,
that,
that's not,
that's not you don't want to do,
you don't want to do that.
That's it.
It's just going to escalate.
And then what do you think's going to happen?
You're going to go down there and kick their ass and will be like,
all right.
I guess it's even then they get,
then they go out and get a bigger crew and they got to top your ass kicking down
right by then.
You know,
it's like anchorman.
You're in that alley fight right then brick kill somebody.
All right,
next one.
So I,
yes,
sorry,
I wouldn't go back to that.
All right.
Just take the ass kicking.
It's a funny fucking story.
Just telling a colorful way and leave it at that as a fucking idiot.
I walked into somebody else's bar,
hammered by myself.
I start grabbing this girl's ass and next thing you know,
I'm admiring the,
uh,
the woodworking of the floor.
Like,
wow,
look at this as,
is this a brass rail that you,
you know,
footstep?
How do they keep it so shiny?
Yeah.
You know,
as you're laying there on your side,
watching them kicking you in the kidney,
you're looking in the refresh ruler,
the,
uh,
the reflection of that brass rail.
All right,
bill,
we got it.
You're on the floor,
popcorn in your hair.
There's a million ways to tell that story,
sir.
Don't go back down there.
You don't want to do that.
All right.
Uh,
hey Billy bin.
Ladin there's another one,
another good one.
Uh,
imagine if you started using a puppet to mix things up.
Oh,
for my act.
All right.
You know the same way Dylan went electric.
You could lose a few fans,
but you'd own the mid West and central Florida.
Dude,
you realize how fucking funny this is.
This is this written by another comedian.
They have that sort of insight.
Do you now?
It's fucking true.
That is
if I stopped doing,
if I kept doing jokes,
but I introduced the puppet,
I already know what I would do.
I thought about it a long time ago.
Five or use the puppet.
What I would do is forever.
The puppet is always smarter than the puppeteer.
I would just stand there berating the puppet and I keep telling it to shut the
fuck up.
All right.
You don't say anything.
You don't even fucking think unless I come up the thoughts.
How fucking dare you start giving me shit with your little feet.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's how I would do it.
As opposed to having a puppet given me shit.
And then I'm rolling my eyes,
you know,
like the husband on a sitcom like,
well,
my wife is smarter than me.
I'm just the dumb fat guy.
Right?
Um,
anyways,
he goes,
here's the thing.
You'd probably be hilarious,
despite the ridiculous ridiculousness of it all.
You lose your mind to being up there every night having a conversation with
yourself,
constantly feeding and unhealthy mental state.
Well,
that's kind of what I do on the podcast here,
sir.
Uh,
he goes,
I guess I should ask a question.
So what would your puppet look like?
Would he wear overalls or a suit?
Would he be an animal or would he even be a he?
It was a female puppet.
You could give it nuggies every time she was acting up.
Yeah.
See you.
See the direction that you're going.
That's the only way to go.
Now with the puppet,
Terry,
whatever you call it,
being a ventriloquist act,
it's just,
it's just so gone in that direction where the fucking puppet smarter than you,
you know,
you don't,
it's funny,
someone's going to steal this idea or they'll be absolutely brilliant taking an
old genre and turning it on its ear.
You know,
it's funny,
he's funny.
He's probably already done it is,
I just in a roundabout way,
just said I had a brilliant idea.
Do you like Dan?
Are you still sitting here?
I get nauseous at this point.
MMM.
No,
that's what I would do.
And then what I would do is I would team up with the dummy and I would start
trashing people in the audience.
You know,
although you know something,
uh,
I dunno.
I am,
I know you're talking about puppets here.
I don't know where to go with that.
Um,
what did we go from here?
Flood.
Let's,
let's,
Oh,
I gotta read.
I gotta read a little more advertising here.
Everybody,
we got to keep the lights on here.
Uh,
where the fuck is it?
Is All the capitals in fucking Europe.
Okay.
We got that one.
You know,
you'd think I would be smart enough,
one of these fucking weeks to just have the only thing's open,
the things that I need,
but I don't have everything up here.
I'm looking at Ebay and some old Ludwig Bass Drum.
All right,
here we go.
Yeah,
we go happy holidays.
All right.
He voice everybody.
Having your own receptionist would be great,
but paying their salary is really expensive.
That's why thousands and thousands of entrepreneurs are now using ie voice to
enhance their image.
Work faster and make more money.
You can try.
He voice right now for free.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com use the use the Promo code bill with he voice
as your virtual assistant.
You get your own toll free number and dial by name directory.
All your calls will be professionally answered and routed wherever you want.
He voice even types.
All your voicemail messages and emails emails them to you instantly.
Just like what the real receptionist,
but without the high cost with he voice your toll free number and virtual
assistance.
Start at 10 bucks a month.
That's it.
You can operate like a top executive,
but stay lean like a startup and blow away your competition.
Ie voice has been mentioned as a key tool for today's businesses and both ink
magazine and Forbes.
So you know it's good.
I believe in a voice and I want you to try it for free right now for 30 days,
go to go to [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
That's [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
Just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the voice banner
right now.
All right,
and they all time classic stamps.com everybody,
you have to know this one by heart.
If you still going to the post office,
why are you,
I'm going to read this one for the last guy in fucking Bulgaria.
If that doesn't know,
you don't want to have to go to the post office anymore.
Do they have the post office over there in Bulgaria?
Huh?
Capital's so fear and that,
right?
Ah,
Jesus.
He's worldly.
He knows a couple of capital's their stamps.com.
There's nothing instance about going to the getting postage from the post office
driving their parking.
It's a waste of time,
so you stamped SARC common stead.
Instantly.
Get postage for any letter or package right from your desk.
stamps.com is so quick and easy to use that even a dummy like me can use it.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer stamps.com
we'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact postage
you need the leave and help you decide the best class of mail based on your
needs.
No guesswork.
Pluses,
convenient.
Take care of your mailing and shipping wherever you need to.
24 seven right from your own desk.
You'll never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I've never had a problem with it.
Uh,
right now use my last name bur bur for a special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus,
including a digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
All right.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com now,
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypebirththatstamps.com and enter
burr.
And finally the last one,
Hulu plus everybody you've tried streaming hit shows on your PC on hulu.com now
it's time to try your free trial of exclusive content and your living room on
your mobile devices,
on Hulu plus with Hulu plus,
you get total control to watch thousands of a TV shows wherever we,
wherever you want,
whenever you want.
Use Hulu plus on connected TVS,
game souls game console's,
sorry,
blue ray players,
Roku,
apple TV,
PC,
or watch from anywhere on your smart phone or tablet on demand at all time,
uh,
all times.
And with Hulu plus you can binge on full seasons.
Watch your favorite current shows and even full series runs of classic TV shows.
It's endless.
They've got community,
modern family,
south park,
SNL,
Jimmy Kimmel,
family guy,
and more.
Hulu plus is only 79,
seven,
nine nine seven 99 per month.
But right now they're offering an extended free trial of Hulu plus that is only
available to podcast listeners.
Take control of your TV watching experience.
Go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com click the Hulu plus banner for
your extended free trial,
or go to Hulu plus.com/bill alright,
there you go.
A couple of options there on how to watch TV this week.
Um,
all right,
let's go back to the letters.
Um,
all right.
Pushover a bill.
I need some standing up for myself.
I need some help standing up for myself.
I live with my mom as a kid and she used to tell me how bad of a father my dad
was and I would say I never want it to be like my dad.
As I got older,
I became every everyone's bitch.
All they would have to say was,
you're just like your father.
And I would do whatever they told me to do.
It wasn't just my mom and my sister.
A lot of my friends pushed me aside to,
I've since moved out,
I'm 23 now,
but people still walk all over me and I'm overly nice to everyone.
How do I stop being everyone's doormat?
Ah,
Jesus,
dude,
you're describing me.
When I was 23,
everybody liked me.
I was nice.
I,
if I met you for fucking two minutes and he asked me to help you move and to use
my truck,
I'd let Ya,
Ya know?
And then when you went to pay me,
I'd be like,
no,
no.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
you got to start.
You guys got to start doing it.
MMM.
And this is the thing,
it's a learning curve.
All right.
Where it's like you can't just be like,
I'm going to start sticking up for myself.
And then the next time you were in a moment where you're supposed to stick up
for yourself and you don't,
you can't consider that a failure because you're least be conscious.
You're going to be,
he got to go through that.
Torture is period where you're now watching yourself getting walked all over and
you go,
well,
here's that situation again and here I am not sticking up for myself,
which will cause you in the short run to be even more down on yourself.
Okay.
Because before,
when it was,
you were so busy
trying to get the other person to like you,
you weren't focusing on what a bitch you are being.
Now you're actually going to watch it all right?
But know that that's part of the,
uh,
road to success.
Anytime you try to break a bad habit,
you know you're trying to quit drinking or you're trying to stop eating late
night and here you are eating again.
You're beating yourself up as you fucking doing it.
That's the first steps,
because before you didn't,
you'd just be shotgun,
shotgun and beers,
right?
Eating ice cream and not even questioning it.
So with this shit,
um,
what can really help you out is if you write it down
bright down,
like,
listen,
I'm tired of people telling me that.
I'm just like my dad.
Um,
you know,
and you know,
you could start with that.
Don't tolerate that anymore.
Just say to your mother,
I want you to stop saying that to me because all you've done is telling me how
bad of a father my dad is.
And so whenever you tell me that,
that's like you're saying that I'm a piece of shit.
All Right,
I'm 23.
Now it's time for me to become my own man.
I don't like when you tell me that it hurts me as a person.
It hurts my development.
All right.
Now how can your mother say no to that?
You know,
easily she could be a fucking pain in the ass,
but I dunno.
Um,
but just,
just start writing down like,
you know,
I don't know.
It's like doing like starting out comedy.
You don't fucking go up on stage,
try to do an hour and kill you.
Just try to hang in there for five minutes.
She just just take baby steps.
And uh,
my biggest thing,
the reason why I wouldn't,
I avoided confrontation is because the only way confrontation when I grew up was
screaming fuck you.
And getting into a fist fight.
So,
you know,
when I would be down at whatever,
bringing my truck in to get it fixed and it felt like I was getting fucked over,
I would be in my head literally going like,
well,
I don't want to fight this guy.
You know,
even if I win,
I'm going to have grease all over my face.
If he gets a couple of shots,
then you know,
it's probably going to grab a wrench.
Like I'm literally thinking that when all I'm doing is getting a tune up and I
feel like,
you know,
or you know,
I remember one time the guy put a new engine in my truck,
my,
I remember,
uh,
it just died.
The thing died and I wanted to make it as a comic and the last thing I needed
was a car payment.
So it's like I would either go out back then you could get a piece of shit for
11 grand.
I'd either have to be 11 grand in debt or like,
you know,
get a new engine put in was like,
12,
1500 bucks sells like,
yeah,
why don't we knock a zero off of that?
So that's what I did.
And I paid the guy and the fucking cunt charge me for the antifreeze that he put
in the engine.
He just would charge me for everything.
I learned a lot.
Never,
never,
uh,
never trusted mechanic that has a manicure and that's not a joke.
He had Cologne,
his fucking nails where we're like pimp level shiny.
So,
um,
but I didn't say anything to him cause I'm like,
oh,
this guy's like,
you know,
he's like 60,
I don't want,
I'm not going to punch a 60 year old guy.
And they like,
and I would be thinking this shit,
but I wasn't even conscious because it just been in my head since I could
remember.
So it's playing on a loop and a lot of shit.
If you finally say it out loud or you write it down,
you realize how wrong it is or how absurd it is.
And it can,
it can kind of kickstart you,
uh,
start going down the right road.
So that,
that's what I would do when you have to be very forgiving of yourself.
Like,
you know what's funny is you're a total pushover probably until it comes to
looking at yourself,
then you probably like a fucking drill sergeant and you're always beating
yourself up.
So I would say,
you know,
try to find the humor in,
in breaking a bad habit or trying to change yourself and uh,
you know,
you work at it every day.
You know,
it's like playing an instrument.
if you play once every three months,
you never going to get better.
But if you fucking play an hour every day,
all of a sudden,
right?
You start shredding and here come the girls and that jumping on your Dick,
all right?
And you start sticking up for yourself.
You start,
they let the women,
they,
they're attracted to that.
I'm not talking about being a Dick,
but women are attracted to fucking like guys who,
they don't want to marry some pussy,
right?
All of them want you to go out there and fucking grab it by the throat and drag
it home,
throw it in the pot so they can fucking cook it up.
Metaphorically speaking.
Last thing I ever want to do is suggest that a woman would want to go into a
kitchen and actually be fucking nice for one
sandwich.
Um,
sorry.
Uh,
you know what I'm saying?
All right.
I hope that helped you out.
Um,
did I get everything?
I get to everything here.
Oh,
cop that shot dog bill,
what's your take on the Hawthorne Police officer firing off one and two?
A dog fucking bullshit.
Right?
Well,
I mean obviously I'm not pro shooting dogs,
but I wasn't there.
I don't know what happened.
Look,
if you're a cop and you're walking in there and some giant dog comes at you with
his teeth showing and is gonna fucking mall your face off,
you know,
I mean,
what are you supposed to do?
But if,
if that shit that,
I mean,
I've seen youtube videos where like the dog isn't doing,
it's just barking like bro,
bro,
Bro.
Cause you're in the house,
but it's not charging.
It's not doing anything.
And they have it standard procedure,
eliminate the threat and they just fucking shoot the dog.
That does brutal.
It's a brutal one on youtube where they went into the wrong fucking house and
they got the guy in the floor and then they shoot his dog and they realize
they're in the wrong house and they killed both his dogs.
It's brutal.
But um,
in defense of the cops,
those are the ones that people put up on Youtube.
You know,
I imagine that they could then show you a thousand of cops going in,
getting attacked by once great dogs that their piece of shit,
scumbag owner turn into a maniac.
So maybe there's some sort of sweeping thing that if the dog weighs more than
fucking,
if you feel threatened by the dog.
Um,
okay,
I'm a,
I'm just playing devil's advocate here.
You're a cop,
you're going into a rest.
Somebody,
they,
you're,
you're trying to deal with does is this person gonna pull a weapon out and blow
my fucking brains out.
I'm never going to see my kid again.
And meanwhile you got does dog.
You know what I mean?
It's like you can only look at one thing at one time.
So in your life is in fucking danger.
I think a lot of people,
including animal lovers,
uh,
we're thrusted,
it's for,
I think it's very easy to not be a cop and just sit there and be like,
dude,
you know what,
I would've done the same way you do.
Like,
you know when you trash the quarterback of your team,
you know what I would've done with my nonathletic ass.
This is what I would've done.
I would've left the leftover,
the fucking defensive line,
you know,
and then called an option or whatever the fuck you would have done.
So yeah,
I may just hearing that story.
Uh,
absolutely devastating.
Cause I know if the cops ever came in my house,
my dog would be flipping out and trying to attack them and I would be like,
let me just put her in the other room.
But if they,
whatever,
we're coming in there and I was considered a threat,
they have to take me down and then my dog would come at them and then they would
fucking shoot my dog.
Um,
and it would suck.
So I'm obviously,
I wish there was a some way that they wouldn't have to do that.
Uh,
but as much as people want 100% blame cops there,
uh,
the real culprit that's set that whole thing off our fucking assholes who turned
that dogs in the maniacs and maybe even someone like myself who doesn't,
I mean I don't know how to have my dog under control,
so I just put her in the back room cause I dunno cause some fucking asshole
fucked her up.
You know that Jesus Christ I got work to do.
Um,
so there you go.
That is the,
uh,
you know what?
I didn't even get to that fucking,
you see that report or that died.
Let me get to where the hell is that story here.
This writer for rolling stone,
which I have a subscription to one of the magazines,
few magazines that I actually read every episode,
every installment.
Um,
Michael Hastings,
uh,
he had a horrible death.
He fucking was going down,
I believe it was Highland,
just south of Melrose is Mercedes was traveling at ridiculous speeds.
He hit a fucking tree and the whole thing exploded bursting into flame and they
had to identify him by his dental records and uh,
allegedly this guy knew.
Yeah,
I guess he wrote some fucking article in rolling stone where he was over in
Afghanistan talking to some higher ups in the military and they were saying some
shit that they thought was off the record and he put it all in the article and
there's people,
conspiracy theorists trying to say that his car was cyber attacked.
Now I'm not even going to get into that,
but dude,
how fucked up is the world getting if like,
that's actually something that somebody could do.
I'm not saying whether it was done by this guy or not.
I have no fucking idea.
He might've been hammered.
I have no idea.
I have no fucking clue.
I don't know anything about it,
but I'm just saying that the fact
that somebody could hack into your computer and cause your car to speed up.
Okay.
And there's nothing you can,
you can't shut the car off.
Yeah.
This is why I don't know that,
I don't believe that it's just like his evil is that is we got to eliminate this
guy.
Isn't there a zillion other ways to kill them without doing that?
Like what if he slammed into like a fucking minivan with the,
you know,
a married couple in their three,
four kids,
you know,
it's gotta be,
can't they just spray some Miss Donna?
Okay.
You know,
just walk up to them in a mall like,
Hi sir,
would you like to try this fragrance?
You just spray it on him and then the guy like,
you know,
10 minutes later and he's trying on some slacks,
he just keels over.
You can't just do it that way.
But anyways,
is this true?
Is can they actually do that shit?
And this makes me feel glad that you know,
half my time out here,
I drive around in a classic car.
You know,
not like I'm any sort of a threat.
But what I'm saying is if that,
if I just would think if you had the ability to do that,
some fucking nerds would just do it just to do it.
Cause it would be funny,
just speed you up for a second and slow you down just to freak you out.
Okay.
You know like do you remember back in the day when this is like pre Internet
fun?
What you would do is you'd take your garage door opener,
right?
And you would drive around the neighborhood and he'd pointed at every garage
until you found somebody that had the same one as you.
And back in the day they just had like,
it wasn't sophisticated.
So not only yours open,
not only yours,
it opened the other ones too.
So you'd,
you'd eventually find somebody that had the same garage door brand is you and
you could open and close the garage.
So at least you could my fucking neighborhood.
So you just find,
you use drive one person nuts,
you'd just drive by and you just fucking,
every once in a while we just open it and I don't know why we would do it.
We were assholes but so using that,
if you could fucking do that.
Um,
yeah,
with cars wouldn't,
wouldn't
like these people like,
you know,
hack in to steal like credit card numbers and shit.
I mean,
wouldn't that be somebody just doing that just to do it like your board?
It was just the,
was this the dumbest part of the podcast?
Everybody did I stick the landing starting off with ignorance and then a why?
Why wasn't gay?
Well we'll fuck you know what the reality,
if I ever book a commercial,
I'm going to be,
you know the commercial where the adults sits there with all the kids and they
go,
you know,
what would you,
what would you do if you had a zillion dollars and then the kids that I can buy
an inmate at a candy.
Yeah,
we could have hot fudge waterfalls and shit.
I would be sitting there right with,
except it wouldn't be like the basketball one where they were like making fun of
the fact.
Like I would be like,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm saying I'm a moron.
Everybody.
Why?
Well,
that's a podcast for this week.
I hope made you feel better about yourself,
at least your intellect.
Um,
I am going to be,
as I mentioned,
I'm going to be at the Cape Cod melody tent on Friday,
Saturday,
and I'm at the Hampton Beach Ballroom Casino.
And then Sunday I'm in down in Newport,
Rhode Island at the Newport yachting center.
All right.
Two tents in an attic.
That's what I'm playing this weekend.
I can't fucking wait.
Um,
I always play Hampton and Newport.
I've never played the Cape Cod Melody Tent.
And this is where,
uh,
the one and only time I ever saw George Carlin's.
So this is a very special,
a Gig for me and there's still a few tickets left.
I'd love for you to come down there and,
uh,
share that experience with me and blah,
blah,
blah.
All right.
Okay.
So there's the outro.
Everybody.
Uh,
all right,
now that the show's over,
don't forget to support all the sponsors.
A quick recap.
Uh,
join the thousands of entrepreneurs who use eve voice as their personal
receptionists.
Um,
Hulu plus you want to start watching favorite,
your favorite hit TV shows right now.
You can all of that shits on the podcast page.
And finally,
dollar Shave Club.
There's no reason to pay all that money.
Everybody,
they're gonna send your blades every month.
You use one a week.
Nice fresh shave and a u side of your face,
smooth as a baby's ass.
All right,
that's it.
Everybody that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
As always.
Thank you for all the emails.
Um,
and uh,
thanks to everybody's been coming out to my shows and thanks to everybody who
went out and saw the heat again this weekend.
Believe it came in third place and it's made a bunch of fucking money and,
and seriously thank you for going out there and thank you for all the kind words
everybody is,
uh,
said.
Um,
to me about the stuff that I did in the movie and meant a lot to me.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.